la décision de justice en appel
concernant à ça traoré a été rendu
public
la jeune militante third adama traoré
morts lors d'une interpellation par les
forces de l'ordre en 2016 a été condamné
pour atteinte à la présomption
d'innocence de trois gendarmes impliqués
dans cette affaire l affaire adama
traoré connaît un nouvel épisode
une condamnation qui intervient dans un
climat déjà très tendu entre les forces
de l'ordre la communauté noire que ce
soit en france ou aux états unis avec la
sphère de la mort de georges floyd tué
par des policiers qui avait déclenché le
mouvement black les amateurs bas c'était
d'ailleurs exprimé à ce sujet le chat
flex ou libertaire donc super de chavez
en france la terre michel z'éclair a
fait beaucoup de bruit il était venu
nous en parler dans tpm p face à cette
haine anti-flic de nombreux policiers
ont décidé de manifester pour plaider
leur cause
pour eux ces débordements sont aussi
dues à une violence de plus en plus
accrue à leur encontre
alors comprenez vous ce qui accusent la
police d'être raciste 21h05 on est en
direct avec booba merci booba d'être là
et je te le dirai jamais assez
tu es vraiment voilà je kiffe racontait
là shoah qui fait avec toi et te
présente un pote ci s'appelle bruno
pomart fondateur du raid homme politique
et je dis voilà exactement il est maire
d'un petit village c'est rien du tout le
village je les ai vus c'est très sympa
bhl
est ce qu'on peut dire que la police est
raciste il pleut il ya des gens qui
disent ça vous dit non on va faire un
petit tour de table à bon droit
c'est marrant parce qu'on parle de la
police comme un parti politique ou un
groupement d'individus qui ont tous la
même opinion alors qu'en fait c'est
juste des hommes et des femmes qui
gèrent d'ormeaux est normal
oui qui travaille et il ya des c'est un
métier très important et c'est des gens
qui pour la plupart font bien leur
travail après oui je crois qu'il ya deux
cent mille policiers c'est ça en france
au total on a malheureusement il ya des
incidents il ya malheureusement des
racistes et c'est évidemment condamnable
mais de là à accuser toute la police et
à cultiver une haine contre toute la
police c'est très dur pour ceux qui font
bien leur travail il y en a plein de
gens j'en suis sûr alors oui et
l'accusation est de plus en plus absurde
que la police et c'est très bien et de
plus en plus métissée donc qu'il faut
isoler les éléments qui sont racisme et
ne pas faire porter l'opprobre sur tout
ça c'est à dire celles à tisser c'est
justement vers nous et le genre de trucs
qui font que voilà c'est pourtant la
vallée c'est important que les jeunes
ont commencé un fils de dire ça il faut
se re tellement bête s'est désolé m à
mesure de l'arrivée des vous aider de la
peau des gens pour les distinguer fois
je sais pas semer mais pas les flics à
mon ami mais c'est là qu'est ce que la
tension se parler du propos jamais la
lutte était raciste je gardais alors moi
je ne dis pas que la police est raciste
mais je comprends plein de gens plein de
jeunes qui accuse aulas et la question
c'est pas la police est radié comprenez
moussa sy a tous je reviens je cotise
parfaitement la comprenez vous ce qui
accuse les mois et je le comprends
parfaitement
parce qu'il ya plein de jeunes qui sont
discriminés parce que contrôler parce
qu'ils ne sont pas blancs dans les
quartiers partout et ça ça existe quand
vous allez gare du nord il ya plein de
jeunes qui sont contrôlés parce qu'ils
sont noirs
donc il ya une majorité écrasante
majorité de policiers qui font bien leur
boulot mais il ya hélas un petit
pourcentage de policiers qui gâche tout
par des faits divers dramatiques et
aussi parce qu'il ya des comportements
oui qu'ils sont racistes et ça je le
déplore et ça me blesse profondément que
la france en soit là kelly on est
toujours en train comprenait donc ces
gens qui me veulent mais moi je le
comprends je ne dis pas que je suis
d'accord mais je comprends qu'il ya des
gens qui ont ce talent villa quand on
voit h 24 sur les réseaux à la télé etc
des faits divers avec la police quand il
s'agit de
deux jambes comme on peut on doit le
site et bac en ce sens que ce soit des
renois des blancs des chinois tout ce
que vous voulez et ben généralement on
voit des vidéos qui nous font chier sur
les réseaux sur la télé etc
donc oui on est obligé de dire à un
moment donné qu'on puisse comprendre
qu'il ya des personnes qui emmenait râle
tu vois alors sur un stade il ya
quelques mois bombes avaient partagé un
dessin qui on disait long regarder le
dessin qui avait partagé booba est
derrière dans une interview tu
paraissais très pessimiste pour toi les
choses n'allaient pas changer de sitôt
regardez j'ai parlé d'une situation
particulière mois exactement ouais ça te
débrouilles tout ce que tu veux qu'on
leur bois ou bien est ce que tu peux
nous en parler ici de son tu parles
d'une situation en particulier par
exactement voilà on vous n'êtes pas
besoin de mettre nos volailles donc là
tu parles de ça deux états unis tu tu as
beaucoup réagit à la tire c'est
compliqué mais c'est pas on pas on parle
aussi beaucoup des flics qui commettent
des bavures etc
mais là aussi tous les jours des flics
qui sauve des gens et qu'on appelle
qu'on a besoin d'un excellent
relationnel et oui et ça fait rire c'est
un long débat il ya des racistes partout
je suis complètement d'accord avec ça
qu'on est là j'ai dit voilà je ne
comprends pas les gens qui dit que les
qui disent que la police terrassant dans
son ensemble va dire la police et
certains sachets samedi les médecins
c'est aussi de dire ça c'est la société
et des conciles où je suis très content
je suis très content en entendant ce que
dit bouba que le moratoire
toi tu as bad buzz et hf durable je sais
ce que je veux dire par là
non ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
et c'est très bien sauf que ces propos
parce que booba a de l'influencé
beaucoup certes hier soir mais déjà dit
des choses et c'est énorme c'est énorme
on comprend et moi le premier tu le sais
bien que je ne sois pas s'il ya des
policiers qui sont d'evian il faut les
sanctionner et ils sont sanctionnés en
nombre tous les armes il faut le savoir
il ya 1000 et 500 policiers qui passe à
la trappe
d'une façon ou d'une autre dans notre
pays il faut pas il faut pas rêver mais
ça existe
est ce que tu dis ça tout à fait raison
c'est que il faut pas faire une
généralité sur le comportement de
policiers parce que encore une fois ceux
là sont sanctionnés par contre ce qu'on
ne voit pas qu'il y à la télé assez
souvent parce qu'on voit ce qu'il se
fasse ce soir ya des faits divers à lyon
et à les policiers qui sont pris à
partie par des jeunes et bien toute la
journée les policiers sauvent tu l'as
dit tout à l'heure ils font près de 3
millions d'interventions il sauve des
gens tous les jours tu joues et ça on ne
voit pas ce que j'ai s'en fout c'est
pour ça que je dénonce ça justement est
ce que je comprends
gens là que je ne vois que ça c'est pour
ça que l'intervention de booba est
importante parce qu'il a de l'influencé
sur les jeunes
moi tu sais mon engagement que j'ai
auprès des jeunes depuis 30 ans raid
aventure organisation c'est une
association qui travaille dans le
rapprochement des jeunes avec la police
gmc solar qui est venu tout autant de
gens connus qui sont venus comme toi et
vous avez une influence qui est
exceptionnel et hyper importante pour
cette jeunesse parce que elle est en
perdition
on a besoin de l'aider moi ça fait 30
ans que j'ai engagé là en tant que
policier j'étais policier mort et
d'avant mais j'ai plein de policiers km
dans cette démarche et des gens comme
toi peuvent nous aider à remonter le je
dirais l'image des jeunes parce que
l'état fois dévalorisé mais en même
temps faire avancer ce ce système dans
lequel on est au gouvernement qu'il doit
bosser surtout oui mais toi tu
n'imagines pas mon échelle mais c'est
énormément de faire et c'est énorme
c'est énorme les jeunes à écouter du rap
moi c'est pas punir ceux qui commettent
des bavures etc
mais ça comme je disais à l'aller 4
qu'on tuait georges cela ils sont en
liberté mais attention ils ont été
radiés et même le service a été dissous
non il ya une sanction très grave
peut-être pas assez forte at home où ça
je l'admets c'est comme les traits de
pédophilie sont radiés ou et des ménages
mais bon oui non mais ils ont été il on
en a pris la sanction c'est la justice
qui décide mais je veux dire il ya
quelque chose de fait ça c'est important
parce que ça c'est une véritable c'est
du véritable racisme et surtout une
véritable l'avion